so 13 years after 9/11 and we must never
forget except for those who already have
step aside al Qaeda or Taliban Evil's
gotten a fresh coat of paint in Isis the
only thing that's changed is the name
but what a terrorist organization by any
other name still smell as sweet
now this administration has gone to
great lengths to ensure that Isis
doesn't tarnish the good name of Islam
now let's make two things clear ISIL is
not Islamic after all it's just one very
small lone extremist group it's not like
Islam promotes murder discrimination or
hatred anywhere else in the world right
except for literally everywhere else in
the world disregarding Iraq or Syria
because they're clearly the minority
let's look to the more moderate Islamic
countries I mean it's not like virtually
all Islamic countries are legally
allowed to kill non-muslim converts
granted that could seem incriminating
but there are places like Pakistan that
have an officially sanctioned the death
penalty so there's that though honor
killings are still common and illegal
what how is the UAE even on that list
it's the most moderate Islamic country
in existence leftists even vacation in
Dubai oh my gosh I love to bow I know
turns out that even in Dubai if you're
Muslim and you try to convert death
penalty that was a crazy night yeah it
was it was so I'm thinking about
converting to crystal and and what about
women progressives and feminists alike
have declared Islam to truly be a
religion of peace of course none of them
live under Islamic rule because sews
broads would be speaking out of turn and
where could they live can't do Egypt
because of the 91% genital mutilation
rate can do Saudi Arabia where women
can't drive vote travel abroad or enroll
in higher education unless their hubby
says so can't do Pakistan where
literally thousands of women are killed
every year in legal honor killings but
what can you expect for a group who make
up a majority of Hell according to
Mohammed sexism be upon him what can we
say ladies if you don't want to be a
hellbound second-class status
and he shouldn't have been born a girl
but let's look back to the most moderate
Islamic country the UAE even there along
with legally killing converts and
banning free speech men can legally beat
their wives
step aside Ray Rice you've got entire
nations in front of you gross human
rights violations in virtually every
Islamic country can you imagine if we
try to incorporate Islamic law here in
America keep your mouth shut that you
know it's good for you in these
countries not only commenced met their
broads around but if you're a woman and
happened to be raped you can go to
prison simply for coming forward even an
ultra super progressive Dubai now you
don't understand that guy tried to rape
me
so whereas Lama Klaw exists even a
little bit we see horrible human rights
violations that would have leftists
fuming if some Southern Baptists tried
to enact them in America so I ask you
again where is this so-called moderate
Islam comment below why are pretty much
all Islamic countries so evil in their
treatment of non-muslims and women not
to mention gay people to answer those
questions and more I'd like to point you
to some quotes from the original Isis
member Mohammed himself
[Music]
you close like this
[Music]
[Music]